asked one of the last shoot was an Oscar
big tournament Toki
oh yeah actually took place here same
venue macaroni messy super dope and now
we're gonna have a beautiful beautiful
soul calibur
top eight the completion for you guys
school versus link course coming up yeah
so we're gonna see up on skill versus
illusion link or so another France
versus America battle we saw this in the
winner side but it's it's we're no
stranger to this regional matchup right
we've seen some America versus France
and that's kinda been the talk of the
talents and this is not just America vs.
France this is skill the man who puts
France on his back up against link
course considered by some to be one of
the best period he's in the USA
maybe maybe the most winningest history
of a Soul Calibur six is a life span for
America right but we're just gonna go
straight into it no button checks
required at these jet jumping right in
this matchup is kind of what I guess we
expected to see a mitsurugi purses girl
this is a footsies matchup it's an
honest see pressure of how to safe play
Gerald it has a little bit of a better
damage opportunity compared to MIT soon
he's got real explosive damage the
special at the 6vv
gallon average right yes but a mid suit
a fresh part a lot of a lot of the low
stuff is gonna be really a knife pick
out nice confront there by him in his
face skill has been sold so strong and
figuring out your button rhythm figuring
out how to mix you up nice like speed be
assured not enough
[Music]
he does have a little bit of armor
throwing down yeah well the while the
yellows flashing on him right
BB nice punish nice Ted cross that was
sick yeah super babies right there GI
who's ready for the stranger ation so
the next time that hit by itself it
should people hit Oh big forth be over
for all guaranteed silver start moves at
one combo by the way oh yeah it with a
double wide damage at the end as well PB
6pp is maybe one of the far right
because of a Venice site if they block
it is safe and ships it pushes back just
amazing move all around where'd you go
to got more than that yeah you trying to
is just a little bit off axis he wasn't
gonna get too much extra after that but
you know anything
rounds straight for link man and now now
if your skill you have to not be feeling
good right now that that was that was a
big big statement first round your link
[ __ ] morale has to be really really
high up and Auntie Joe has something
really quick now you can see the look of
consternation on his face he's uh it
seemed a little bit confused you guys
admits you guy you're kind of used to be
the one that's dancing around everybody
else and being the world round it kind
of guy yeah controlling the pace of the
neutral game around through the non
right but everything is not hearing that
right now nice one ace just checked it
with of QAS I love the decision whenever
I step though how it's great yeah the
one eight the one a and the two a boat
just good little ways for girl to to
track you low because of both
horizontals follow-up do it for the 440
this time yes yes I was about to say I
didn't want to call it for sure I think
it yes
it's so hard to get away from the wall
once skill get started here what a widt
mr. back step on the make spending so
chives oh he went straight for the inky
but he didn't get the follow up Robson
trying to push him boy it's so much dead
oh good block under-18 but no one is he
tried ah my BB I'm sorry I'm too scared
playing solo nice transition he finally
went for the bait because earlier he was
always doing the low right hmm GI yeah
we mentioned earlier how he was ball 24
those straight out so scary but he got
away so he works out yeah no no he was
trying to get Wow nice to lay on that
yes he charged it up a little bit since
VP silversword for poor people get off
me yeah unfortunately that does not stop
soul charge all right no good block that
one wasn't punished too but I said he
went for the help speed good mix it's
enough
this is the leaflets taper up around cuz
he flashed but that would I don't know I
guess we're about to find out you might
get off oh my god so far did stick yeah
what an amazing to work with you so you
might fritter employee betrayed not
gonna help the block the block under 100
my goodness anything it's gonna
eliminate the Soul Calibur world
Invitational champion
school's out I cannot believe it the
level of plays somehow just continues to
advance from everyone